comme un adversaire qu'il a toujours
réussi à faire plier en pariant qu'il
n'y aura jamais d escalade avec des
alliés
il continue à affirmer ligne diplomatico
militaire indépendant par rapport à ses
alliés de l'otan tout en se déclarant un
membre totalement fiable de cet
organisme la négociation sera difficile
avec un interlocuteur qui n'hésite pas à
se mettre sur la ligne rouge pour forcer
le destin
[Musique]
elle a une l'état d'urgence décrété
pendant deux semaines à beyrouth après
la double explosion dans le port et hier
le bilan est encore provisoire au moins
113 morts 80 blessés des centaines de
milliers de sans abri un traumatisme et
un paysage d'apocalypse qui domine à
l'origine de la déflagration un stock de
2007 150 tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
sur place on cherche encore des disparus
la situation est chaotique dans les
hôpitaux nous ferons point on direct
depuis beyrouth dans un instant
la solidarité internationale s'organise
pour envoyer de l'aide au liban du
matériel médical du personnel mais aussi
des hôpitaux militaires allemagne
al-bakr on doit se rendre demain dans la
capitale libanaise la france déplore au
moins 21 blessés le parquet de paris a
ouvert une enquête
une aide du monde entier en provenance
notamment de la russie des états unis du
qatar et l'iran et d'israël pourtant en
conflit avec le pays du cèdre
sur le front de la pandémie oms rappelle
aux jeunes leurs responsabilités pour
éviter de propager le coronavirus cet
été d'ailleurs le port du masque dans
les espaces publics ouverts se
généraliser en france
en europe les pays sont de plus en plus
nombreux à suivre cette voie
nous verrons que c'est le cas en
allemagne et en belgique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france et on commence
avec ces images chaotiques à beyrouth
près de 24 heures après le double la
double explosion dans le port et ce
terrible bilan humain au moins 135 morts
5000 blessés et des centaines de
milliers de sans abri un dernier bilan
toute la journée les secours et les
habitants ont cherché des victimes des
proches disparus dans les décombres un
paysage d'apocalypse des recherches qui
se poursuivent
l'état d'urgence a été décrété au liban
pour deux semaines des routes et déclaré
ville sinistrée du côté des hôpitaux
déjà durement frappé par la pandémie
deux pour laver russe est la crise
économique c'est la saturation
d'autant plus qu'ils n'ont pas échappé à
l'effroyable explosion dans deux
établissements cinq infirmières ont péri
touché par un plafond qui s'est effondré
et des débris de verre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
déjà commencé à envoyer du matériel
médical au liban et de nombreux pays
également la france la russie les
etats-unis le qatar l'iran et même
israël avec qui le pays du cèdre est en
conflit dans le nord pourtant à paris
dépêches trois avions militaires dont
deux avec un détachement de la sécurité
civile de 50 cents personnes 15 tonnes
de matériel 6 tonne de matériel
sanitaire la france qui déplore au moins
21 blessés le parquet de paris a ouvert
une enquête
écoutez le colonel vincenti ciel revient
sur l'aide apportée aux paysans de y
alors c'est du matériel déjà pour un
terminal pour se courir donc des
médicaments des intrants médicaux c'est
du matériel technique pour intervenir
sur les toits sur les façades pour
sécuriser les façades pour rechercher
des victimes ensevelies pour les dégager
pour les médicalisé la médicalisation de
l'avant voilà c'est et puis également à
du matériel pour notre autonomie
logistique puisque l'idée c'est
d'apporter de l'aide au pays et pas lui
demander de l'aide
donc on est autonome en alimentation en
vivre en hébergement dans des conditions
rustiques
on imagine pour bon nombre de libanais
les deux explosions meurtrières et
dévastatrices sont la catastrophe de
trop un compte tenu du contexte
économique exemple à la destruction du
port c'est 60% du transit d'importation
qui partant qui part en fumée à la
situation est dramatique le point avec
elana ferradj un terrain ravagé
aujourd'hui semblable à une zone de
guerre
partout des conteneurs éventrés des
valises des chaussures et même des
voitures qui sont maintenant transformer
en épave le port de beyrouth
construit en 1887 et qui faisait la
fierté du pays du cèdre était autrefois
en symbole de modernisation le point de
contact entre les pays de civilisation
arabe et les nations d'europe et
d'amérique écrivait même jean loge unie
dans un ouvrage de géographie en 1956 un
port qui n'est désormais plus qu'un
souvenir
les conteneurs ont été soufflées par
l'explosion plus de 2700 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium partis en fumée un
désastre pour l'économie du pays qui met
donc au tapis un liban déjà fragilisé
par une crise économique et sociale sans
précédent
il faut dire que le port de beyrouth
d'une surface de 120 hectares et est
l'un des plus fréquentés de la
méditerranée orientale avec l'aéroport
international rafic hariri
le port était l'une des deux principales
portes d'entrée du liban des explosions
qui porte un coup dur aux pays qui
dépend en majorité des importations dont
plus de 60% arrivé dans le port de
beyrouth une activité économique qui
représent
tu es en 2018 plus de 20 milliards de
dollars parmi ces importations figurent
notamment des produits alimentaires
influent qui correspond à 80% des
denrées consommé au liban gardons à
l'esprit que le port est la principale
route commerciale du livre c'est là que
nous recevons notre blé by notre gazole
nos médicaments
cette infrastructure est totalement
détruit à l'heure actuelle chaque dollar
qu'ils entrent au liban est vital pour
nous
le port de beyrouth est également dû
faire face à la destruction de
gigantesques silo à grains des
réservoirs importants pouvant contenir
plus de 120 mille tonnes de céréales est
essentielle à l'alimentation des
libanais ce n'est pas du tout le moment
le liban traverse une grave crise
économique et le port et le poulain du
liban pour l'importation de produits
alimentaires et de tout autre chose
nous comptons sur le port vers cela les
libanais sont dorénavant pris en étau
entre ce désastre et la menace
d'effondrement économique
une situation amplifiée par la crise
sanitaire qui a aussi réduit le
fonctionnement de l'aéroport de 10% de
sa capacité
seule voix d'importation alternative
pour le liban sa frontière avec la syrie
dans le nord et l'est du pays dans la
région un autre pays a par ailleurs
proposé son aide israël
pourtant en guerre avec son voisin mais
la situation reste malgré tout
préoccupante également pour les autres
pays limitrophes du liban comme la syrie
ou la jordanie
très dépendante de l'acheminement de
denrées qui transiter par la capitale
libanaise
et selon le gouverneur de beyrouth les
dommages sont estimés à plus de 3
milliards de dollars on va écouter
michel fayyad et analyste politique et
financier les ports au liban c'est toute
son histoire parce que le liban c'était
l'histoire de la phénicie c'était ses
ports c'était son commerce vers le monde
entier que ce soit en interne
d'exportation d'importation
c'est toute son histoire toute sa vie
économique qui est touché j'ai en terme
de reconstruction du port
parle de 3 5 milliards de dollars à cela
il faut ajouter ce que le gouvernement
était en train de négocier avec le fmi
donc on parle de 5 à 10 milliards et ce
qui était prévu par la conférence aidera
paris il ya quelques années qui était de
11 milliards de dollars qui était donc
qu'ils sont à être ajoutés au ski et
promis par le fmi
donc c'est une enveloppe importante le
problème aujourd'hui au liban c'est
qu'il ya une en fait un conflit larvé
entre le entre les partisans du plan du
gouvernement qui est qui est un plan
acceptable par le fmi et dont les
chiffres ont été validés par le fmi et
de l'autre côté les banques et les
politiciens qui ont des conflits
d'intérêts avec celle ci et qui ont
présenté un plan d' alternative qui
consiste à vendre en fait les réserves
d'or de la banque centrale
la façade maritime du pays où les biens
immobiliers de l'état
et ça c'est inacceptable par le fmi et
par les libanais enquête va se dérouler
au liban pour faire la lumière sur les
circonstances de l'accident
une question comme en 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium a pu être entreposés
dans un bâtiment du port c'est une
substance à l'origine d'autres accidents
mortels dans le monde notamment celui de
l'usiné azf à toulouse en 2001 regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
l'actualité sociale en france ils
réclament une prime qu'ovide les agents
de sécurité des gares lyonnaises ont
entamé un mouvement de grève aujourd'hui
un véritable bras de fer est engagé avec
la direction de leur entreprise les
précisions sur place de miss curbelo
avec l uqat sûrs c'en est trop pour les
agents de sécurité des gares lyonnaises
ce mercredi matin
rendez vous était donné devant la gare
de la part dieu un rassemblement à
l'appel de la cgt avec un objectif clair
obtenir une prime qu'ovide d'environ
1000 euros pour les 700 salariés de
l'entreprise bsl qui ont travaillé
pendant la pandémie
parmi eux bader maoudj un salarié très
actif dans le mouvement social
il affirme avoir été convoqué par sa
direction en vue d'un licenciement
nous étions aux premières lignes comme
les caissières comme les hommes comme
les comme les infirmières dans ce
domaine pendant la pandémie mais on a eu
aucune reconnaissance à part des mails
venant de la direction nous dire bravo
bravo de ce que vous faites bravo mais
cela ne suffit pas nous avons réclamé un
geste auprès de l'employeur il a balayé
tout ça d'une main il n'a rien voulu
savoir
ils ont fermé les bureaux tout ça pour
pas nous recevoir
onfray nous s'il vous plaît on veut
négocier auprès nous peine perdue la
porte de la direction ne s'ouvrira pas
pour les manifestants certains salariés
expliqué que les équipements de
protection ne sont arrivés que fin avril
soit un mois et demi après le début du
confinement selon le syndicat le bilan
humain est dramatique
seigneur nous on a ressenti au niveau
national plus de 17 salariés décédés du
coup vide sur des salaires qui était un
problème sans aucune protection ou le
remerciement de ses boîtes aujourd'hui
c'est non sanctionné pour ce que
revendique la prime voilà on laissera
pas faire on est face à un combat de
classe aujourd'hui en l'absence de
réponses favorables les militants se
disent déterminés à poursuivre la grève
dans les prochains jours et ce sont les
grands oubliés de la culture et sont
venus manifester aujourd'hui ou au
panthéon à paris les guides
conférenciers en colère ils dénoncent
des conditions de travail précaires et
lors d'une manifestation silencieuse
apparaît regarder des gisants des
pleureurs une faucheuse une scène censée
représenter la mort du métier de guide
conférencier une profession menacée
depuis la crise sanitaire pas de
touristes pas de revenus mais toujours
un loyer à payer les guides
conférenciers demandent des aides de la
part de l'état écouter ses réactions
nous n'avons plus de travail donc pour
les guides salariés les japonais les
guides en japonais sont souvent salariés
donc nous n'avons plus de salaire et
même si nous sommes au chômage nous
avons nous pouvons avoir le chômage en
fait nous épuisons nos droits sans
pouvoir les recharger nous demandons
donc d'avoir une année blanche pour les
salariés puisque ne pouvons pas
recharger nos droits et des aides
jusqu'à ce que la reprise du travail se
fasse peut-être en 2021 et surtout par
exemple pour les guides salariés en fait
toutes les réponses que nous avons sont
faites pour les autres entrepreneurs
le gouvernement est en train d'essayer
de pousser les guînes vers l'auto
entreprenariat on essaye de se rendre
visible et surtout de lutter contre eux
une mort certaine annoncé étant donné
qu' une partie des guides plutôt
importante n'est toujours pas aidé donc
on avait promis au moment du début de
cette crise que personne ne serait
laissé au bord de la route
malheureusement il ya des personnes qui
passent dans les trous de la raquette et
les guides conférenciers salariés en
font partie mais là l'urgence absolue ce
sont les guides conférenciers salariés
pour la plupart multi employeurs en
mission très courte en mission d'une
demi journée à huit jours si vous partez
en circuit mais il ya du travail
y a pas de touristes on le voit bien
dans pareilles a pas de touristes au
moins 1200 communes impose déjà le port
du masque à l'extérieur dans l'hexagone
pour faire face aux coronavirus
deuxième vague est possible cet automne
ou cet hiver selon le conseil
scientifique qui appelle au respect des
gestes barrières et selon lui près de
10% de la population française a été en
contact avec le virus il faudrait
atteindre 50 à 60% pour protéger est la
population je vous propose d'écouter
jacques bonnaud il est maire du mont
saint michel il a pris un arrêté qui
rend le port du masque obligatoire de 10
heures à 18 heures dans la cité intra
muros
il était à notre invité tout à l'heure
comme tous lieux publics en france je
pense que c'était la bonne la bonne de
la bonne décision
tout en sachant que le mont lorsqu'il a
été d confiné
l'affluence est revenue progressivement
faire qu'au bout de deux mois
la première chose morceaux lorsqu'on
sort d'un confinement
c'est pas se dire ah chouette je boirai
au moins cinq chaînes maintenant nous
sommes dans une configuration autres à
savoir le retour en masse des visiteurs
retrouve la même fréquence que dans les
années 2015 de 8 à savoir environ dix
mille personnes par jour lors de
week-ends est effectivement là la
différence ce sont des touristes locaux
[ __ ] locaux nationaux et européens
nous n'avons pas là l'affluence des
visiteurs asiatiques sécurité renforcées
dans les transports en commun ministre
de l'intérieur et les transports ont
annoncé aujourd'hui le doublement des
patrons eu deux gendarmes et policiers
il s'agit de lutter contre la
délinquance les caméras de surveillance
sont rendus obligatoires et des lignes
téléphoniques dédiées sont installés
dans chaque commissariat les deux
ministres s'exprimer à l'issue d'une
réunion du comité national de sécurité
dans les transports en commun on va
écouter gérald darmanin
je voudrais également évoqué le fait
qu'avec les constructeurs dont monsieur
le ministre un rapport privilégié par
ses délégations
mais aussi par les réseaux de transport
qui appliquent les appels d'offres des
élus et par les élus nous souhaitons
nous revoir tout au début du mois de
septembre afin de signer un engagement
général sur la vidéoprotection
consisterait à qu'il n'y ait pas de
nouveaux matériels qu'ils soient achetés
des bus des trams des métros des trains
évidemment évidemment des équipements de
gare 100 caméras de vidéoprotection que
ces caméras de vidéoprotection doivent
être absolument
en lien avec question de supervision
urbain des communes dont vous savez que
c'est le maire qui a la vision pour
protéger sa collectivité
il nous faut faire un petit audit pour
savoir quelles sont les communes qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas accès aux images
des caméras de vidéo protection des
réseaux de transport notamment de la
gare qui est souvent un lieu de
criminalité ou de délinquance
et troisièmement nous avons décidé d'un
groupe de travail qui rendra ses
conclusions afin avant la fin de l'année
sur l'application de l'intelligence
artificielle par ces images de vidéo
protection
elles portent des masques n'arrangea
rien elle suscite des tensions dans les
transports en commun les lieux publics
aussi en france et à l'étranger en vie
en images sur des incidents de plus en
plus nombreux depuis quelques semaines
regardez
[Musique]
on
moi
[Musique]
non
de nombreux conducteurs se joigne à
notre projet ils viennent au gymnase
afin d'être prêt à faire face aux
agressions qui se produisent tous les
jours
la simple règle du port du masque
devient un problème pour les conducteurs
[Musique]
et sachez que l' oms a rappelé aux
jeunes leurs responsabilités pour éviter
de propager le coronavirus cet été port
du masque heures en intérieur ou en
extérieur en tout cas la mesure se
généralise en europe pourtant au début
de la pandémie ce n'était pas forcément
la tendance regardez
[Musique]
quand
et vous
[Musique]
oh
en italie la pandémie de lakovic 19
alimente la pression migratoire le virus
a rendu encore plus compliqué la gestion
des nombreuses arrivées quotidiennes et
le stration à amélie ni le récit est
signée hélène masquelier tous les jours
des centaines de migrants continuent
d'affluer dans le sud de l'italie alors
que le pays doit affronter les
conséquences de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
qui l'a frappé de plein fouet
des camps sont bâtis en urgence
notamment en sicile pour accueillir les
nouveaux arrivants un centre
d'hébergement aménagé dans une ancienne
base militaire provoque la colère des
habitants locaux coupable et nous sommes
très inquiet ce n'est pas m être raciste
mais on n'avait pas besoin de ça les
choses sont toujours décidée sans
concertation avec personne c'est comme
si personne ne vivait ici a commencé
comme on disait
nous sommes une communauté nous faisons
partie de vision mais cela ne me semble
pas juste parce qu'on ne sait pas quand
il fallait repartir
personnellement je suis très inquiète
parce que j'ai déjà des problèmes de
santé alors ça m'inquiète je ne veux pas
que la situation empire aussi pour cette
raison je pense que ce n'est pas vrai
que pour moi mais aussi pour tous les
citoyens de bizi nice
face à ces nouveaux flux de migrants la
droite nationaliste italienne fustige la
réponse jugée laxiste du gouvernement
transalpin
de son côté la france renforce sa
coopération avec l'italie
gérald darmanin s'est rendu à rome la
semaine dernière
il souhaite la mise en place d'une
brigade communes aux frontières ne pas
trop le mix c'est très important entre
la police italienne et la police
française le long de la frontière on
sait tous que lorsque la frontière et de
chaque côté gouverné par sa police les
passeurs se joue de ces différences de
législation de ces différences de
langues des différences de pratiques et
le mérite malheureusement revient à ces
passeurs qui trafic des êtres humains et
donc cette papouilles mixtes
franco-italiennes une grande avancée
l'italie a pour sa part demandé à la
france d'intervenir auprès du
gouvernement tunisien pour alléger la
pression migratoire sur son territoire
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
italien sur plus de onze mille migrants
arrivés depuis le début de l'année 4000
proviennent de tunisie un pays dont
l'économie a été lourdement affecté par
l'épidémie de kovy de 19
l'ex président colombien alvaro uribe a
assigné à résidence dans le cadre d'une
enquête pour subornation de témoin s'est
lui-même à qui l'a fait savoir sur son
compte twitter à la tête de la colombie
de 2002 à 2010 et les notamment connu
pour avoir à dénoncer l'accord de paix
signé avec les farc ses partisans
dénoncent une politisation de la justice
alvaro uribe attend désormais la date de
son procès
la privation de ma liberté me causent
une profonde tristesse pour mon épouse
pour ma famille et pour les colombiens
qui croient encore que j'ai fait quelque
chose de bien pour la patrie et à
écouter l'analyse de julienne quel fou
querelles et secrétaire national du
parti de gauche responsable
international des jeunes un sioniste
c'est la première affaire où on voit le
prêt de l'ancien président uribe qui se
retrouve en fait un peu face à la
justice qui va enfin devoir rendre des
comptes à la justice et pour le peuple
colombien en tout cas quand on connaît
son histoire récente
ça peut en tout cas représenter que des
choses très positives
le rapport de forces qu'on en vient tout
simplement changé depuis l'époque uribe
ou est-ce qu'il était en plein pouvoir
avec l'appui des forces du narcotrafic
et de ses milices qui lui permettait
d'avoir un plein pouvoir et d'être très
populaire en colombie on a vu depuis
quelques années une contestation sociale
forte en colombie une fracture sociale
qui a mis la population contre les les
forces politiques un phénomène
destitution on a vu les taux notamment
un mouvement social très puissant au
colombie en décembre janvier derniers ce
rapport de forces est fracture sociale
qui existe cette structure
institutionnelle qui existent a ajouté
en plus récemment avec la question du
coc vide puisque la gestion du coc vide
et particulièrement en combi est
absolument catastrophique on est à onze
mille morts les mesures historiques
daury b qui avait été de privatiser des
services publics notamment de la santé
on voit les conséquences aujourd'hui
donc du coup uribe n'est plus
intouchable et c'est tant mieux et tout
de suite à travailler car tu es sur le
web une sélection d'articles à retrouver
sur l'a36 terre fait france pointait que
les chiens
un homme soupçonné d'implication dans
l'attentât de strasbourg a été remis en
liberté les suspecté d'avoir fourni une
arme à chérif archers 4 qui on le
rappelle avait tué cinq personnes à
strasbourg en décembre à 2018 selon une
source judiciaire y penser qu'al armes
allaient servir à un braquage
l'homme a été placé sous surveillance
électronique a retrouvé donc sur notre
site et en gironde le maire d'un petit
village agressé hier par un individu
très alcoolisé après avoir protesté
contre vie tapage nocturne à la suite de
son agression
l'élu a déposé plainte à la gendarmerie
il a également reçu le soutien du
ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin à retrouver donc sur
votre site arte france pointé
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver en
direct dans 30 minutes ça rester avec
nous sur rtl
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes pieds
coup politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la veille mais idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent pour la haine en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui est
extrêmement divisé le magnat société
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]